can we expect a showdown between the
Caped Crusader and the gentleman of
crime and Max's the penguin believe it
or not there may be a chance even as
James Gunn and Peter safran's DC
Universe prepares for its highly
anticipated launch director Matt Reeves
of Batman Universe is still going strong
following the 2022 hits the new debut
branded mag streaming service has its
sights set on a television spin-off the
series puts a focus on Colin Farrell's
Oswald Oz cobblepot also known as The
Penguin in Gotham City's criminal
underworld naturally with this premise
in mind you have to wonder if Robert
Pattinson's son's Batman will make an
appearance though many details of the
penguin remain under lock and key rumor
has it that Pattinson himself will
indeed pop up briefly on the show this
information comes from the hot mic
podcast where co-host Jeff Snyder shared
a tantalizing tidbit word is the patents
and is going to appear in the Penguin
series oh Snyder also knows that he's
unsure who Pat and son would appear as
Bruce Wayne or Batman with that we'll
just have to wait and see what Reeves
has in mind for Pat and CERN on the
small screen if anything at all in live
action specifically Batman has had a
complicated relationship with television
the spider host of DC shows coming to
fruition with some even focus on bat
Family characters such as Robin and
Batwoman over the years the Dark Knight
hasn't made many direct appearances in
most cases is either missing retired or
just briefly mentioned you're a female
Bruce Wayne awesome hilarious
handsome therefore it's fair to wonder
if Robert Pattinson's Batman could even
take part in a project like the penguin
thankfully James gern has cleared the
air when it comes to the mystery of his
potential appearance in March 2023 a
Twitter user made a post regarding
alleged handcuffs that would prevent
Patton's son's Batman from appearing on
the penguin according to their Source he
would likely only be able to appear with
Bruce Wayne or under his Drifter Persona
a supposed legalities make it next to
impossible to put Batman on TV gum was
quick to respond to that claim with a
very succinct this is not true while
this isn't confirmation that patinson
will pop up on the penguin it is
confirmation that there at least isn't
any legal red tape to stop the show
Runners from including him as a Caped
Crusader regardless of whether or not
Robert Pattinson appears as Bruce Wayne
or Batman on the penguin fans Haven't
Seen the Last of the actor in DC media
the Matt Reeves directed The Batman 2 is
indeed on the way with Pattinson set to
return in the title role naturally
speculation has begun to run rampant
over who the main villain or villains
could be now that Paul Dano's Riddler is
behind bars some suspect that Barry
keogan's Joker could take the Spot while
Pattinson himself has his fingers
crossed at the course of owls will
feature I was definitely kind of
thinking quarterback was probably going
to be in the sequel definitely seems
nice mommy I'm literally just guessing
meanwhile Colin farewell to share that
he'll be more than happy to return as a
penguin for another cinematic Showdown
with Batman under Reeves Direction the
actor told variety's Awards circuit
podcast I'd love to be in the Batman too
I loved working with Matt I just think
he did such an extraordinary job in that
film it's unknown if farewell's penguin
will factor into the story of the Batman
2 but if Max says the penguin doesn't
give fans another clash between us and
the Dark Knight hopefully the highly
anticipated sequel will
[Music]